It may be that the tanning process was too sweet to wash my face
. It's the work of scraping off the complaints and spatula that remain in Senkawa. If
this is sweet, it will not
last long.  It
's not suitable for people with sensitive skin, so it's recommended for everyone.
[Music]
What do you think? Suru
3-san,
that's nice, it's very nice, Aidai-kun
[Music]
Nice,nice
Edo Mai Goon, the cutting edge of the times,
I want to see more Edguy-kun, I want to see more boss-like costumes,
like Miku-chan  I'm walking like a cat,
cute
[music]
What is this
?
You hit your mother, blowfish
, turning your face to your mother, it's time to decide,
edguy, you're the kind of person
who has to be like that.
Yes
Mom died of a heart attack
Should have settled this while she was alive
Thank you
[music]